What are you thoughts on multi versus,
well,
you see this is different because
this is the what? Sequential.
So I don't call it a multiverse verse.
They each influence the next one.
And so they're not independent worlds.
Right.
But indeed the possibility
of Independent. Yeah. Well,
you see, there are two reasons
for believing multiverses.
One of them is the quantum reason that
maybe we have the shouting is dead
Katherine and the livecast,
they in different worlds
and they separate universes.
I don't believe that argument.
I don't think that's the right
way to look at quantum mechanics,
but many people do.
And that suggests that you might have
these multiple universities in some sense
on attractive about that to you.
It doesn't explain what we see.
So he wanted the theory, which explains
the world we see and the world we see.
You get collapse they state does.
And to explain that,
well it's only because we've drifted off
into some world and another version of
ourselves as drift into another one and
some c one and the other side of the
other.
And they're all in super position.
It doesn't explain why.
You see one world and she
has this kind of coherence.
I mean lots of people try and there are
many attempts at the sort of thing. It's,
it's quite a widely held view and
if you believe quantum mechanics,
the collapse is not real and it doesn't
happen. And all the alternatives,
the dead cat under LiveCap
coexists in different worlds.
That's the interpretation. That's
a view. I don't think that I want,
I want an explanation for the world
we live in and you don't see cats,
different worlds with cats
and well it's a long story.
I mean it's clearly,
it's a view you can hold to and if
you don't want to monkey with quantum
mechanics is where you lead. So that's,
that's right. That's the alternative. I,
they don't make a single triad to
change quantum mechanics at all.
And then you are led to this multi world,
many,
many world picture. I think it
even doesn't make that much sense.
So you've got to be careful about it.
That,
whether they are really like different,
distinct worlds, I don't think it really,
my view is it doesn't really work
well let me not trying to attack that.
And I think I have a different view,
which is that the theory is not quite
quite right. Right. And that, um,
there is something which makes the,
the collapse into a
physical process and uh,
the, there's only one world
now the other many worlds view,
which is comes from a different reason
and that is that they seem there seem to
be various accidents, um, in,
well maybe one of them being that the
neutron is just slightly more massive than
the Proton. That's one. There
are lots of other accidents.
We see that if they were a little
different than life as we know,
it couldn't happen. And so how do you
explain this? Well, some people say, well,
all these universes with different
values of these constants all coexist.
It's just we only see the one that we're
in because the numbers come out right
for us. So that's what's
called an anthropic argument.
Okay. I can see the argument. I
didn't like it much. It's sort of,
I think we need a better explanation for
why the numbers of what we see and so
on. But that's that that one makes
more sense to me than the other one.
So I saw, I think one, maybe
it has to take that seriously,
but certainly not the viewer I'm
presenting here with this picture.
It's for someone like me.
It's so interesting to know that
there's still a considerable amount of
speculation. Yes. Oh
yeah. Well it's, it's,
there's a lot of speculation,
but a lot of it is pretty off the wall
and then other people think mine are off
the wall and see whose,
who's to say, okay, I'm,
I'm no man. And so, okay. You know,
did in decent things in the past,
but you just didn't trust this abuse now.
So I guess that's what people
think. I don't know. But
you see, if it was just me,
I could understand that.
But I've got these posts and I have an
Armenian colleague who's done things on
this too. And A, it can't be that we're
all all off the rails, I think. No,
there's something out there.
And now with their hawking points,
there's something people can
really go out and look for,
and if they don't see it and there's
something funny going on somewhere,
if they do see, then there's
something else going funny on which,
which they'll have to think of another
explanation, unless it's my explanation.
They'll have to think of a different
view from the current inflation view,
which is in real trouble with these
observations. As far as I can see.